[Musique]
c'est le jour J le lancement du Big tour
à Saint-Quentin en Yvelines nous sommes
le mardi 20 septembre et pour parler du
Big tour un événement co-organisé par
BPI France et Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
nous sommes avec Patrice bégaye le
directeur exécutif de BPI France Bonjour
bonjour à vous alors vous êtes même le
fondateur du Big tour alors là on est
dans les coulisses il y a une émission
qui va commencer à 9 heures c'est vivre
ta ville ça fait un moment déjà que vous
faites le tour de France pour aller à la
rencontre des entrepreneurs français là
c'est la dernière étape aujourd'hui oui
on fait le tour de France comme vous
dites c'est le festival des
entrepreneurs l'innovation et l'emploi
nous aurons reçu sur ce plateau ici
1200 invités cette tournée rendez-vous
compte 30 étapes un peu plus de 40
invités par étape il y a à la fois toute
la partie des entrepreneurs locaux etc
qui sont là il y a le grand village du
Big tour sur l'innovation etc et puis à
l'intérieur du vélo de Rome et à ce
fameux job dating
on va aller tout de suite voir ce qui se
passe
sur ma droite on va voir skywan Portal
donc c'est une startup spécialisée dans
le développement de solutions de réalité
virtuelle et on voit ici un monsieur en
train d'essayer justement avec le masque
de réalité virtuelle à ma gauche le
Latmos qu'est-ce que va présenter le
l'Atmos aujourd'hui sur le Big alors moi
je vais présenter plus un axe en lien
avec un département donc on nous sommes
en train de développer des petits
satellites petit satellite dédié à
l'observation de la Terre et du climat
donc nous allons vous montrer quelle
technologie nous développons donc des
satellites et ensuite on va aussi parler
de quelques thématiques comme l'Arctique
parce que nous observons les zones
polaires pour voir un peu les effets du
réchauffement climatique et ensuite on
vous montrera aussi des instruments que
nous avons à bord de la Station spatiale
internationale donc ici vous avez un
exemple d'instrument qui mesure le
spectre solaire
[Musique]
le Sky éco sur le Big tour le festival
des entrepreneurs Patrice se poursuit et
on se poursuit avec le
lneck qui est directeur général adjoint
du ln bonjour bonjour
actuellement on travaille beaucoup avec
nanobiotique qui produit donc des des
médicaments qui sont portés par des
naines matériaux pour aller soigner la
cellule cancéreuse donc au plus près
donc là on voit vraiment qu'on est dans
une utilisation complètement positive de
l'innovation mais derrière après se pose
justement la question de la
caractérisation est-ce que le
nanomatériaux il va vraiment fonctionner
est-ce que c'est reproductible et vous
voyez on revient encore à ces questions
de métrologie et on va se tenir au
courant sur le Sky Eco de l'activité du
LNE dans les prochains mois merci
beaucoup c'est beaucoup merci je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur général
adjoint du ln attrape
je vais voir les PME voir des jeunes
entrepreneurs et puis regarder avec eux
de quoi ils ont besoin pour que on
améliore encore la vie des jeunes
entrepreneurs je pense qu'on a encore un
gros chantier de simplification pour que
on développe l'entrepreneuriat dans
notre pays moi je vois les résultats sur
l'emploi sur la création d'emplois
notamment pour les jeunes il faut
continuer à soutenir l'entrepreneuriat
au maximum
[Musique]
l'entreprise c'est la vie c'est la
solution
avec l'innovation bien sûr derrière avec
la modernisation de tous les métiers le
travail c'est je vous rappelle une
valeur d'émancipation c'est une valeur
d'épanouissement c'est une valeur de
dignité aussi donc l'emploi c'est un
salon de l'emploi de l'innovation de la
création de la formation si je rappelle
qu'on est en Paris c'est clair à des
premiers lieux dans le monde de
l'innovation classant les 8 territoires
d'innovation au monde
Saint-Quentin c'est le c'est le poumon
économique de Paris sinclay et c'est en
fait un eldorado de l'innovation
[Musique]
l'édition spéciale du skyco se poursuit
au Big tour à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et on va parler de cybersécurité on a
avec nous François et nolfejas PDG
d'oxybox bonjour si tu es à Guyancourt
alors votre spécialité c'est de
développer des solutions de sauvegarde
finalement quand une entreprise point à
une infrastructure se fait attaquer et
bien son activité est sauvegardée c'est
ça alors tout à fait alors oxybox pour
être précis on est spécialiste de la
sécurité de la sauvegarde c'est à dire
qu'on édite une solution de sauvegarde
sécurisée mais également une solution
qui permet de garantir la sécurité de la
sauvegarde pour qu'elle soit exploitable
après une cyberattaque
le
coffre école 2600
Valérie Saint-Père absolument et Lionel
ou une école de 1600 c'est au fond
l'école de la cybersécurité alors en
fait on a décidé de monter cette école
pour répondre à un enjeu stratégique au
niveau des filières on s'est mis au
niveau des partenaires privés que du
regalien pour pouvoir former des experts
en cybers sachant qu'il en manque a
priori à minima 35000 spécialistes en
France actuellement le projet a été ici
il y a plus de 8 ans suite à une
collaboration dans un laboratoire de
sécurité assez connu en France où on
travaillait sur l'émission donnée par
lassis on s'était promis aujourd'hui
monter une école de cyber avec certaines
spécificités si on prend par exemple ici
on a la Seconde Guerre mondiale si
jamais la France se former en 40 on va
éviter de mobiliser les troupes 3 ans
après donc on voulait avoir finalement
une école en alternance pour répondre
immédiatement vous allez reprises parce
que l'avantage que l'intégralité de nos
étudiants ne paye pas leurs études
celles-ci aujourd'hui par la taxe
d'apprentissage collecté par l'État
reverser aux branches qui nous finance
mais ce qui me permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir des étudiants qui sont
immédiatement opérationnels aujourd'hui
on est sur une filière qui est
relativement jeune donc effectivement
des formations de spécialiste en
cybersécurité c'est essentiel et ça
n'existait pas avant donc on est obligé
de rattraper le retard qu'on a en la
matière en sachant déjà les filières
informatiques gérées traditionnelles
manquent elle-même également de
personnel la spécialisation en
cybersécurité et le fait de pouvoir
avoir des experts dans ces catégories là
et absolument vital pour que la France
soit compétitive en la matière il y a un
plan cybersécurité très ambitieux qui
avait été annoncé par le président au
précédent quinquennat et pour être mis
en oeuvre tout simplement il faut qu'on
ait les ressources pour le mettre en
oeuvre
[Musique]
et l'un des secteurs ou l'innovation est
forte et bien c'est la finance à travers
ces fameuses fintech Patrice et là on va
en parler justement avec le fondateur de
corporat est-il Cyril mansince bonjour
bonjour à tous les deux et puis merci de
l'invitation
[Musique]
vous dites que vous allez devenir la
référence mondiale de l'information sur
les entreprises exactement l'ambition
c'est de venir la référence de toute
l'information des entreprises alors
quand on parle d'information des
entreprises on parle de toutes les
données qui sont publiées par les
entreprises donc c'est frappe
principalement des données financières
mais on parle aussi de communiquer de
presse donc on parle au-delà des
chiffres aussi de du texte et du
contexte qui accompagne la donnée et
avant de d'attaquer le monde on se
concentre bien sûr sur sur l'Europe
avant la levée de fond on a eu la chance
d'être accompagné par ski cube par un
prêt d'honneur parce que ça prend du
temps de lever des fonds et si des
entrepreneurs nous regardent ça prend
toujours plus de temps que que prévu
donc on a sollicité le territoire
Saint-Quentin pour nous accompagner via
un prêt d'honneur ce qui nous a permis
aussi de lancer notre levée de fonds et
d'aller chercher les meilleurs
investisseurs sur nos sujets et le voilà
pour faire court
pratiquement sans intérêt il est alors
avec zéro intérêt appartement garanti en
partie et accessible vraiment de manière
très simple donc par 50 ans initiative
et en plus on était déjà incubés donc ça
facilité on va dire l'obtention et puis
ça donne voilà une bouffée d'oxygène
pour les entrepreneurs surtout dans une
période où les levée de fond sur latex
ce sont on va dire un peu compliqué un
peu plus difficile ça nous a permis
voilà de gagner quelques mois et d'aller
chercher les meilleurs investisseurs en
toute tranquillité et donc on a annoncé
en effet cette semaine mercredi levée de
fonds donc de 2 millions d'euros près de
d'investisseurs professionnels donc et
là il y a partenaire qui a un fond
spécialisé en fintech
fifty partner et vice capitale Partners
accompagné bien sûr aussi de business
angel
d'entrepreneurs spécialistes de la
finance ou de la de la data et donc
s'effon nous servent aussi à voilà
développer la commercialisation et
surtout dans un temps très court à
recruter donc c'est pour ça qu'on était
là aujourd'hui
de deux personnes de tous les secteurs
donc pareil voilà si les gens nous
regardent
bien sûr des ingénieurs en informatique
ou des Data scientist c'est vraiment le
cœur de notre activité de métier puisque
l'actif principal de la société c'est
c'est une base de données donc il faut
voilà il faut la maintenir il faut
développer les outils qui permettent d'y
accéder mais on voilà on recrute aussi
des profils plus marketing ou
commerciaux
[Musique]
la journée se poursuit sur TV 78 oh big
tour à Saint-Quentin en Yvelines le
festival des entrepreneurs est présent
sur le territoire pour sa dernière étape
et nous sommes dans le vélo de Drôme
national de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et
autour de moi et bien c'est un big job
dating avec des entreprises et des
demandeurs d'emploi qui viennent pour
trouver l'opportunité d'un côté les
recruteurs pour trouver le bon candidat
et de l'autre et bien les demandeurs
d'emploi qui viennent trouver le bon
emploi et l'une de ces entreprises qui
vient de recruter et bien et il y a Reck
Nowak cette startup spécialisée dans
l'économie circulaire qui réutilise
finalement les déchets plastiques et
nous sommes avec la fondatrice et la
dirigeante de cette start-up Hugo lin
solaire bonjour bonjour Nicolas alors
qu'est-ce qu'une start-up vient
rechercher comme profil sur ce genre
d'événement
alors ça peut être assez varié parce
qu'on recherche des choses des profils
qui sont assez classiques comme
assistant de direction assistant
commercial ça peut être des profils plus
atypiques et ça permet justement ce mode
de rendez-vous de un quart d'heure de
croiser des gens qu'on n'aurait pas
forcément l'idée de de prendre en
entretien traditionnel donc on a
rencontré quelqu'un qui travaille le
bois à son compte qui pourrait peut-être
faire du proto pour nous on a rencontré
quelqu'un qui était plus orienté
commerce grand format bon c'est un petit
peu tôt mais ça permet de commencer à se
préparer à des embauches un peu plus
conséquentes dans les dans les mois à
venir donc c'est vraiment un format que
j'aime beaucoup moi quel type de profil
vous recherchez des personnes qui sont
bon je pose motivé mais est-ce que il y
a une formation un niveau de diplôme à
avoir
non non ça va dépendre évidemment des
profils donc ça ça c'est ça se trouve
sur les annonces en fait il nous faut
des profils évidemment motivés par le
développement durable qui ont compris ce
que ça voulait dire des profils qui sont
conscients qu'à ce stade on va pas leur
proposer des rémunérations de grands
groupes ou des rémunérations énormes
donc voilà il y a un effet d'engagement
et de monter en puissance du projet qui
qui justifie un petit peu de
modération salariale on va dire merci
Hugo line merci à très bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]